all right so if you've been looking for
that next just great fun Indiana Jones
Adventure I think I found it for you
[Music]
uncharted drake's fortune all right so
the Uncharted series is exclusively for
the PlayStation 3 don't whine Xbox
people you still have halo uncharted
drake's fortunes the story of Nathan
Drake who believes that he is the last
living descendant of Sir Francis Drake
yeah you know the guy who looks like the
Burger King yeah that guy and he is set
out to find what Sir Francis Drake was
apparently looking for El Dorado and to
all you people who are gonna be like I'm
actually a Sir Francis Drake never
actually looked for El Dorado
oh let's Nathan Drake once said well
history can't be wrong you know but I
personally was like all right the El
Dorado thing I've seen it a hundred
times before how can this be new and
interesting but it really is for me the
moment that title screen queued up and
the music started playing the Uncharted
theme I was like dude this is gonna be
awesome
just from the theme I knew and I was
right a lot of that gets credited to
nolan north a guy who voices Nathan gray
when I first heard the game I was like
dude is that Nathan Fillion from Firefly
totally sounds like him and it
absolutely does the character Nathan
Drake must have been based off of
Malcolm Reynolds from Firefly except
Nathan Drake is a little less damaged
he's like all the fun of Malcolm
Reynolds without any of the damage so
it's all good in his world and so when
you set off to find El Dorado you got to
solve a bunch of temple puzzles a lot of
it relies on jumping from point A to
point B the guy's like a monkey he must
have the craziest upper body strength
cuz that guy can climb anything and yeah
you have a lot of other people looking
for El Dorado also and they have guns
and Nathan Drake throws down there's
something about these archeologist
treasure hunter types
Indiana Jones Nathan Drake they can all
snap necks with the best of them and
Nathan Drake's a badass now the weapon
system you've seen a few times over you
can have your two-handed gun like a
shotgun an ak-47 whatever and a
one-handed gun magnum 9-millimeter
whatever you can only have one of each
at any given time sometimes it a groove
Eights me because I'm one of those I
want the best of all worlds kind of
people I want my rocket launcher my
shotgun my ak-47 my nine-millimeter my
Magnum my Uzi I want it all I know that
would severely break the game so I
understand why they do it this way but
you won't keep me from bitching about it
you pop headshots you don't need
shotguns or any of that [ __ ] and since
you're never being pursued by Ray Park
from Sleepy Hollow it's all good
headshots all the way you love them
headshots and the environments are
really cool it's a lot of tropical stuff
getting around can be kind of annoying
it does the basic 3d camera thing where
you need to jump from point A to point B
like across the pit onto like a 2x4 and
you can't swing the camera behind them
because there's like
all right they're great I gotta jump
across this pit at like a 76 degree
angle let's do that with an analog
controller I'm gonna die and you do and
you hate it that only happens a couple
times so it doesn't compromise too much
to the fine the puzzles are never really
hard there are never those puzzles that
you're like I don't even know how to
solve this this is [ __ ] there are a
couple scenes where you're like this is
so cheap it's stupid happens a couple
times in the game one part in particular
is the very end of the game it's like
three phases you just gotta take the
guys out but it's so cheap
it'll aggravate you which means I'm
charted goes from do this is a great
game every PlayStation 3 owner should
have one is this is awesome
- this is so cheap it's stupid quite the
night in day scenario but great script
cool adventure clever dialogue funny
dialogue it's like modern Indiana Jones
without the fridge that survives a new
cuz that would be stupid Nathan Drake is
the guy that every guy wants to be the
graphics are a little dated it came out
a few years ago so they're not as
detailed as games nowadays are but when
everything else about the game makes you
forget about that that's something good
the Uncharted games man if you have a
PlayStation 3 you should have uncharted
drake's fortune and have you played
Uncharted what did you think about it
comment below let me know and stay tuned
next week which kind of makes me sound
like a network television station when I
say it like that when I review uncharted
2 among thieves and if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]